how is it that the city of miami ends up
with a treasury and then also earning
bitcoin yield meroswara's just turned
his city into like an oil producing
country that yields bitcoin and i'll
tell you how that happened when you mine
city coins like miami coin 30
of uh the cryptocurrency that you're
sending in to mine goes directly to the
city so you know when you mine bitcoin
you spend electricity when you mine city
coins you spend cryptocurrency that
crypto just happens to be stacks which
happens to yield approximately 10 apy in
bitcoin that's a nominal yield so if the
value of stacks goes up the yield goes
up commensurate to that when you're
sending in those stacks 30 to mine 30
goes directly to the city's treasury
that's why the city of miami has almost
22 million dollars worth of stacks after
just three months of this protocol going
live now that number is just going to go
up and up and up and up and up in terms
of stats and therefore the amount of uh
bitcoin that that treasury can yield
will also uh go go up as a function of
uh the stacks being added to the
treasury ongoingly just being added so
okay that treasury yeah so once you get
that treasury there and they are
generating the bitcoin yield that is
what uh mayor suarez in miami is saying
he is going to take the bitcoin yield
and he used a very specific term of a
dividend right he's basically going to
give that to the citizens
now my understanding and what some of
the questions we're around is we don't
have all the details right there there
isn't necessary like hey here's exactly
how this is going to work but the high
level uh appears to be that any citizen
can come in they can get any digital
wallet doesn't matter what company what
brand you know whoever built it uh
custodial non-custodial the whole nine
yards
they then will get
some
future to be determined amount of that
bitcoin so the citizens are getting
bitcoin in a digital wallet that they
control it's not a city created um a
digital wallet like a chevo wall or
anything like that this is just off the
shelf from the market uh but it's a
dividend it's not the city going and
buying bitcoin in like the open market
and turning around like handing it to
citizens that's right so you know cities
city the reason cities don't just buy
simply buy bitcoin is because taxpayers
would be so incredibly uh mad at them if
they did that because they're maybe um
maybe asking taxpayers for money out of
their own pockets to get bitcoin uh what
what suarez did with miami coin is he uh
added tax revenue he added non-tax
revenue to uh to the city that they can
distribute to to uh folks in terms of
bitcoin now um that's right and uh in
terms of like people using wallets i i
believe the city is looking for uh the
sort of best possible uh you know way to
do this in a uniform
you know kind of like sensible way so
like i don't have all the details um
they're gonna determine that but
one thing i think actually could be
really useful here is using lightning
channels and getting the city set up on
not just bitcoin but lightning and uh
ongoingly uh sort of metering out
bitcoin
and how would that work
um so
the city has to figure that out
essentially that's like they're talking
to folks from from lightning uh from
different lightning uh sort of uh
companies
and essentially what would happen is uh
all the bitcoin that's yielding from the
um the city's uh stax treasury would go
into a wallet uh that would set up set
up uh you know payment channels with all
the sort of citizens or might go into
multiple wallets and uh be sent
automatically you could also do it
without lightning but there's a lot of
citizens and i'm sure lightning would be
helpful
so for example uh and i'm just gonna use
one that i uh one i'm an investor in but
also two i understand intimately and
they've done a bunch of like payment
bitcoin type stuff is somebody could go
they could get a strike wallet and the
city could use the lightning network
take the bitcoin that they've earned as
part of that yield and then pay out to a
user who has that strike wallet uh and
that's the way that the city would
essentially be sending bitcoin to a you
know private citizen
yeah i can i can chime in on the go
ahead how this can work so basically
think of this as uh let's roughly call
it at 20 million dollars worth of
treasury uh with a 10 yield you're
talking about two million dollars worth
of uh bitcoin projected but this this
might actually given given that the
donations these are kind of like
donations coming into the treasury so
donations might keep going up right so
it might be like a 50 million treasury
we don't know
we'll see how this turns out but the
yield is dependent on that so let's call
it anywhere between two to five million
dollars of bitcoin uh once you start
looking at it as bitcoin in satoshis
that's actually a pretty large number
right so you're you're you're because a
single bitcoin has like 100 billion
satoshis so you're talking about a large
number of stats that are available for
these citizens and you don't want to
lose a lot of them in transaction fees
right so the ideal way to do it is over
lightning like you help people set up
lightning channels imagine like the
entire city government would have to
understand lightning they would have to
build up their own lightning
channels which is super exciting the
amount of education the bitcoin
education that happens over here and
then the people who on board not
everyone's going to on board right so it
might seem like okay maybe five million
dollars worth of bitcoin isn't a lot a
it's a lot in sats b not everyone is
likely going to onboard only the people
who actually go through the learning
journey of what bitcoin is what lighting
is i i think this thing is valuable and
i want to get some for me the biggest
benefit here is the learning journey
when people they get their first
satoshis like in their wallet they
experience a payments rail that is fully
decentralized that is a new type of a
sound money i think that's the thing
that that explains excites me the most
about
what's going on in miami and then
patrick talk to me about new york it
seems like obviously there's this like
uh competition going on now i wrote this
morning about we've got four mayors
across the united states that are all
getting uh a portion of their salary
paid in bitcoin we have cool valley
missouri uh jason stewart there he's
paying out um about a thousand dollars a
bitcoin to his citizens uh the city of
new york is now saying eric adams hey
we're going all in on this stuff like
how do we become a leader in this space
so what's going on in new york yeah so
uh eric adams is watching what suarez is
doing and he's seeing a new model for a
mayor right so this is a mayor that
makes out group arguments to pull uh
talent and capital into their
municipality which is really smart most
mayors don't even realize that this is
uh this is this is uh
essentially a game that's going on right
now they're essentially most mayors are
like asleep at the wheel in terms of
like um uh how to be a mayor in the 21st
century in this regard and so eric adams
uh is refusing to just uh be like your
prototypical uh 20th century mayor and
he's looking to compete with with suarez
and so he saw miami coin he said he saw
he was doing well and he said he wanted
to
go in that direction so the community
decided to activate new york city coin
new york city coin now has two million
dollars in its treasury that is uh that
they can do it with whatever they want
uh that two million dollars can also be
stacked or in bitcoin they could
literally copy suarez and you know
become that oil producing country that
gives a dividend to their citizens um
but i think essentially you're gonna see
this like this decade you're gonna see
tons of mayors competing for talent and
capital just like a ceo of a company
would be and the reason being the reason
for that is that um
we are essentially living in like a
default remote first world for
information workers so people are
choosing cities like their choosing
products
and um
and and so you know
you know you moved from new i think new
york to miami um during the pandemic
you've never been happier
and you chose miami like a product and
you love miami so like um you know city
coins is great too just like as an
additional thing as just like another
way of voting sort of right so like you
used to build a vote with your ballot
and uh with your feet you voted with
your feet to miami i don't watch your
vote on the ballot so i don't know if
you're voting but now you can vote with
your coin you can the market can signal
uh their approval or disapproval of um
of essentially how capital is spent and
how the leadership performs so if you do
you mine or buy or build on city coins
you are committed to the city oh sorry
sorry if you hold city coins you're
committed to the city if you mind buy or
build you are bullish on city leadership
if you sell certain city coins you're
bearish on city leadership